many young adults did not have to go
very far to spend thanksgiving with
their families because of the pandemic
pew research says a majority of them are
already living with their parents
nearly 3 million u.s adults moved back
in with their parents or grandparents in
march and april
we spoke with a few of them laura
hopkins left a teaching job in mexico to
move in with her parents in california
eric rivera left brooklyn new york after
he was laid off and moved in with his
parents in new jersey
will francis left l.a to move back home
with his parents in alabama
and chrissy walker left new york city to
work from her parents home
in texas
[Music]
at first it was really fun it felt
really special we got to celebrate days
that i'm usually not here for
and it felt nice and then it got
old cool life
[Music]
almost all of my immediate family was
able to come back home for
the first couple months it was almost
like being in middle school again
i was able to play video games with my
brother i learned how to make sourdough
bread
it's tough but very very rewarding
after being away from home for quite a
while i feel like i've kind of regressed
back to my teenage years i'm back in my
childhood home in my childhood bedroom
i have chores again so i'm responsible
for the dishwasher
getting the plates if i'm out with
friends and i'm just having a couple
drinks my kind of initial
reaction is to sneak in and now i keep
reminding stuff like eric you're 30.
over here is my work from home set up
one of the perks of
moving back home would just be that i
have a lot more time for myself i don't
want to commute
so i've definitely been a lot more
productive
before covert there wasn't really this
tradition of group facetime calls and
but now i've got a group of friends that
does it once a week
i have not cooked a meal for myself
probably in the past like four months
one of the biggest highs about being
home now
is being able to spend more time with
friends and family i'm home for people's
birthdays my friends
children's baptisms and special
occasions
just little simple moments that i was
kind of missing out on
i just moved to a new city by myself
i've definitely
kind of found my independence moving
back in with my parents was not
something that was on
my game plan for any point ever really
i think the hardest thing was just not
being ready to say goodbye
to what my life was like before i don't
know when i'll be back
and so kind of just accepting
this new reality and just going with it
definitely the hardest part is the
uncertainty not knowing how long how
severe it would be how much it would
affect like the economy and job
opportunities
it's hard to make goals or plans when
you just don't know
what the state of the world will be
when i was in the city a lot of my
friends were laid off or furloughed so
we'd kind of be able to figure out what
our next plans are and how can we help
each other so being home
it's a little polarizing away from that
world it kind of starts spiraling out
like am i ever going to move out of this
house
i just found myself with no real options
other than
moving back home for a little while
these are very uncertain times
um and you know i'm just trying to get
through it my dad now gets
the fact that when the door is closed he
shouldn't come in thanks dad but i teach
right in front of a window
until he'll always come in and like wave
um and i'm just like okay literally okay
avocado toast
my basic day consists of getting up
really early since i
i teach in mexico city it's a two-hour
difference it's hard but
the kids make it worth it i'm feeling
mud
because of the core virus the
coronavirus it makes you mad
got it i really appreciated this time
working from home
and i want to you know take that kind of
authority over my life back with me to
new york and this
good work life balance that i've curated
i'm generally pretty excited and
optimistic about life post-pandemic i'm
still hopeful about finding a job and
moving out on my own again
but that timeline's a moving target i'm
hopeful that you know things will go
back to semi normal whatever this new
normal will be
but that's just what time will tell
[Music]
yeah some people can and i think that's
what's really great about this story is
the fact that they have a place to go at
a time where some people are just
still trying to figure it out or that is
a great point it really is
my son never left like so many freshmen
who had to go virtual for college he
yeah his friends it's tough for them
we're gonna have to wait just a little
bit longer
yeah yeah thank god for
russell and jonathan his pod
you know so thank you